russian opposition leader alexey navalny
is now urging the people of his country
to stage daily protests against vladimir
putin for his invasion of ukraine
meanwhile back at home president biden
issued a rallying cry during his state
of the union address to unite the nation
and the world against vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine as he as he vows to
make russia's leader pay for unleashing
war in europe
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met the ukrainian people
brett when you think about state of the
unions you know i think about landmark
moments historic moments we all remember
johnson laying out what we now know as
the war on poverty uh the axis of evil
comment by by president bush uh bill
clinton pivoting saying the era of big
big government is over i don't recall a
line last night a moment like that last
night that will make this state of the
union go down in history your thoughts
definitely not and it was a speech that
was workmen like it was the traditional
shopping list of a president trying to
get things done from congress a congress
that is divided and not getting what he
wants done
the speech was not really inspiring it
wasn't lofty
there is unity on the ukraine issue and
you have to give the biden
administration credit for reaching out
to all these nato and eu countries
getting them singing from the same sheet
of music there are critics that say this
is leading from behind and he's letting
the other nations kind of lead the way
on toughest the toughest sanctions but
he is
steering and talking and and engaging
with all of these countries so on that
part of the speech and that part of the
sanctions and kind of going down that
road i think he had some success the
rest of it really
was lackluster and
you can't point to something that says
this is going to change the dynamic they
have the ability the moment to shift to
make a decision they're going to shift
policy you're going to go after
independence you're going to open up
energy you're going to do something big
swing for the fences there was no
swinging there was no fences
there were there was nothing
as far as big in the speech yeah that's
a great description harris you know one
thing that stuck out to me um
there's a key moment of silence i should
say that uh that that we did not hear
president biden mention the 13 fallen
and look i know you don't want to
mention the lowest point in your
presidency i get that no president does
um but in my view i wish he would have
just given a slight nod to the 13th
fallen in afghanistan you know i i don't
think that that is
too much to ask that he would put that
into a more than hour-long speech in
terms of
the substance of who you are as a
president as the commander-in-chief i
think you're right about that and if
anybody had any doubt if well you know
maybe he didn't have time or whatever
for certain avenues
i watched last night and it it at times
to me and i know he has a lot of crises
going on but i think it made more
emphasis on that on just how much has
gone wrong in his presidency to hit it
like a laundry list i mean it's kind of
like on the fourth of july when they
have the last barge and the music is
over but they have to light everything
so they just put all those fireworks on
display and it's like a blue a red a
gold and none of it makes sense i mean
after a while i thought we are
indiscriminately going down a list here
of things that look definitely stick out
on the polling as non-delivered items
for him in terms of his agenda um you
know the words
i'm going to secure the border i thought
i had hallucinated for just a moment
there like well and then he didn't go
into how and i know senator cruz and i
were talking about this last hour well
was he going to secure the border with
the wall like what what was the plan
going to be
but all of it was sort of
touch but don't go deep
touch but don't go deep yeah go to go to
ukraine but don't go so deep that you
would say that there would ever be a red
line and definitely tell them that
military is off the table which i
nobody wants to go to war but don't you
say that
you know all things are possible if
if
i don't know i'm not a general but we
didn't go deep last night no we didn't
go deep
and josh rogan from the washington post
he pointed out there was a series of
tweets of things that were not mentioned
in the state of the union uh check this
out shannon syria perhaps he didn't
mention syria because he has no serious
strategy at all and has turned a deaf
ear to the cries of the suffering there
almost no mention of china it's almost
as if biden didn't was so focused on the
near-term crisis he's losing focus on
the long term no mention of north korea
maybe it's because he doesn't have a
plan with kim jong-un's growing
dangerous and provocative actions the
list goes on my point here here's
another one on iran
many of our adversaries weren't
mentioned many situations on the world
stage just simply did not make it in
and that's something the president had
been lauded for during campaigns and as
a many multi-decade senator himself that
he was the foreign policy guy and yet
all of the polling shows us now that
americans increasingly do not trust him
on issues of foreign policy they weren't
good things for him to bring up last
night and really with everything he has
on his plate i don't think he wants to
start anything with rocketman or anybody
else out there because it is a very full
plate um i it was interesting that he
avoided those they were just some clunky
things there were new segues we're
talking about one topic and all of a
sudden the next sentence is on to
something else towards the end he was
doing sort of some of the weird
rhetorical stuff he does where he starts
sounding like he's screaming and the
ending that nobody can figure out um it
definitely wasn't one of his best
speeches but with all the polling
against him um and domestically and
internationally so many fires uh burning
at this point i think he just wanted to
get it done and get out of there can we
just talk about two things one is the
folks the over under on folks was it had
to be about 35
35 36. the over under on folks
and then the end to shannon's point you
know god bless the troops god bless
america and go get him is that what he
said
he said go get him go get him go get
that yeah i wondered
yeah uh emily we were talking about that
last night what was go get him
referencing i mean who knows right isn't
that the answer to every question trying
to elicit clarity from that guy's speech
you know brett mentioned the lackluster
equality and shannon mentioned sort of
the shouting and i shouting is no
substitute for resolve or determination
or seriousness and those three things in
my opinion were lacking in addition to
any type of lucidity and clarity uh his
talking points were so exhausting when
he moved on right so let's get into the
sort of extra
x's and o's that we were talking about
last night they were exhausting because
we keep hearing them because they're
over generalized and over simplistic
like you're saying because we've been
hearing them since he was candidate
biden he has never supported or failed
to support with any type of policy or
any type of achievement because there
has been none and when he did reference
things
he failed to take structure he failed to
take responsibility for his policies
role in either exacerbating or creating
it so when he talked about the the
children's response from social media
right and then they're declining mental
health well what about the the absolute
mental health decline from the pandemic
he talked about appointing a doj
prosecutor for pandemic related fraud
what about the fact that it was his
bungling of the dissemination of those
funds that created that um and finally i
thought you know the the too little too
late distancing himself from the defund
the police movement i frankly found
offensive there's a lot more but i know
we're running out of time but i had a
lot of issues with that speech last
night just real quickly on
infrastructure when when that was one of
the things that he touted that he got
done and in fact that that did get done
but the supply chain crisis then
undercuts anything that you would
immediately want to do
on infrastructure in certain areas right
and he didn't address how it wasn't in
fact santa claus who was going to bring
a resolution of supply chain issues that
we have we're not making enough in the
united states there was no call for any
of that look he had the time that list
was long he could have slid in some
substance yeah yeah between fund the
police and secure the border when things
clear it's a midterm election year i
went on brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now